Let's go next to where do we want to go next?
I mean, there's just so, so many so many places
to go.
Let's try our caller from the 9 7 3 area code.
I believe 9 7 3 is Jersey, which I would be
interested in hearing from.
Who's there today from 9 7 3.
Hi, this is Jack.
Hey, Jack, where are you calling from?
I'm calling from North Jersey, North Jersey.
So how are things there with the virus because
that is an epicenter.
Well, currently I'm at my office desk right
now.
I think I super do about this person in my
building died were doing.
You have to come in to work at your temperature,
taken nurses right at doors.
You have to do questionnaires, make sure you
come and get it.
You're not crazy.
It's a state or federal government job, if
I recall correctly.
This is actually a D.O.T. contractor, so it's
not, I think, state or federal, but we work
with the federal government.
Got it.
So my question was regarding something that
you brought up a few weeks ago on your show
about the popularity of progressive policies
and how when they're asked in a certain way,
people do not actually approve of them or
like them.
And I think you could say that for most policies
and one of the reasons why the right and conservatives
able to gain so much popularity and win elections
is because they know how to properly phrase
what they want to get the American people
to stand behind them.
There was a great book written in 2004 after
the Bush reelection called Don't Think of
an Elephant by George Lakoff.
Of course, had read it a whole book.
Now you, George, about it.
Very important book.
They have varied phenomena.
I just read it recently, but I think what's
important for the left is that we need to
work on our framing and our messaging when
it comes to our policies.
Because I do believe they are very popular
policies.
But for example, Medicare for all it has to
be presented to people in a way that is digestible
enough that it doesn't sound like something
that's radical.
Does it sound something that's crazy or impossible?
It sounds something that's realistic.
One of the ways I think that could be done
is when we think about people arguing for
more money going to the military, they say
we need to strengthen our country.
We need to have a strong defense.
We need to protect Americans.
I would argue you would should use that same
type of language when saying we need a universal
health care system.
You know, we need our America.
We need Americans healthy.
We need a straw.
We need a strong working base.
We need strong citizens.
Yes, health is strength, health is safety,
etc.
We are we are a strong country when everyone
has the ability to stay healthy and we don't
want to be.
I mean, it's almost like getting into this
alpha beta lame language that they use.
We don't want to be Beda by being weak and
not letting people get the health health care
that they need.
You're sort of getting into that idea of strength
versus weakness, alpha versus beta.
Yeah, and that's that's, I believe, how a
lot of people think, yeah.
You know, a strong father mindset.
I also want to interject one more thing about
the election in November.
Yeah, I am a libertarian, socialist, a member
of the DSA.
I volunteered for Bernie.
I donated for Bernie, a phone bank for Bernie.
And I'm going to be voting for Joe Biden and
November Bhuttos not voting for the person
who is directly running against Trump is helping
him get elected.
So I'm trying to optimize as much damage as
possible.
Well, listen, I think, you know, producer
Pat is on the line because he's tracking what
we're discussing here.
I think our first three calls are Bernie guys
working for Biden.
Yang Guy is voting for Biden.
Socialist is voting for Biden.
I mean, those those are our first three YouTube
titles, I think, from these three calls.
All right.
Well, thank you very much, David.
You're doing a great job.
Pre-great, appreciate it.
Great to hear from you.
And stay safe there in New Jersey.